hey guys goodness I have a fitness app
you get to workout life with me and
other amazing trainers every single day
go on done appear on the App Store or go
to fear live.com and start your journey
to become today we are going to work on
your glutes and also apps so it will be
a total of nine lower body exercises
these exercises will get your legs your
glutes scouted and you will have perkier
butt so let's get warmed up okay so to
begin with stand sugar with a part with
your toes pointed forward I want you to
just place your hands just on their toes
and I want you to just stretch up
straight the legs
squat down look straight ahead stretch
up and squat down okay so we want to
just lower your body stretch your
hamstrings work on your glutes through
your quads and stretch on your
hamstrings as you come up
so straighten your legs chest up and
just loosen up the muscles very good
keep going give me five more right down
and up down and up if you're struggling
with this what you can do is release
your hands and just squat down come up
squat down and come up good last two
more down up and good
now give me few reverse lunges okay so
stand forward step back and step forward
and step back okay what I wanted to add
in is a small twist so as you step back
twist the opposite side good twist and
look the opposite side very good down
twist step back twist work on the core
at the same time twist down and twist
good keep going this is just your warmup
keep twisting down and twist
last one more on each side down and
twist good now just stand up I want you
to open up your hips okay so just stand
tall
oh but ever hips to the left and to the
right most of the time we tend to work
on the front and we don't really work on
the side playing a case to open up
keep going side up keep opening up nice
give me three more up out one more last
one and just shake it out okay good
so the first workout will be a single
lick lunch if you have a step up or if
you have a small table use it alright so
what I'm going to do is step forward
with your right leg okay lift your left
leg up place it on top of your small
table or a stepper or even just a bench
okay I want you to find your balance
tighten across squeeze your core in take
a wide step forward not too wide okay
and then just place your hands by your
waist and lower yourself down push
yourself back up and lower yourself down
okay
so in order for you to find your balance
remember look straight ahead
are you ready let's go in five seconds
okay so each workout will be for 45
seconds long tuck your belly in down up
down and up good so your left leg should
just gently rest on the bench that's it
all the work should only be on your
right leg good keep going down push up
with your heels and push up so you
should be pushing up with your heels and
not your toast all right down it up
lunch down up and very good keep going
nice so control the movement small
movement okay nice and control look
straight ahead
keep your body upright so do not hunch
forward keep your body upright one more
and release let's work on the other side
okay so same thing you will find that
either your right leg or your strong leg
will be lot stronger
you're right licker your left leg will
be stronger okay now left leg forward
right leg up okay find your balance
let's go down and up good down and up
very nice so remember pushing up with
your left heel okay good
got it up nice okay very good
find the balance suck in your belly
strengthen your core good beginners if
this is too tough just take a small
logically small ash and come back up
as you progress lunch deeper ha and
those exercises will work your leg
muscles your glutes as well as your
hamstrings trust me they will be on fire
alright now shake it out next workout
squat abductor so what I wanted to do is
then shoot it with a pad toes pointed
forward stay in a low squat open and
close your knees just like this so
squeeze it open squeeze and open okay so
you should be working on your gluts as
well as your legs so this is what it
should look like squat down maintain
open and squeeze push it out push it out
so really engage your glute muscles push
it off squeeze it back in push it
squeeze it in and push very good nice
feel your inner thighs as well as your
outer glute
this is a really good outer glute
workout keep squeezing push it last few
more look straight ahead
maintain a low squat one more and just
shake it out now take your mat get down
onto the floor and we want to work on
donkey kicks okay so get down onto all
false what I want to do is
lift your right leg up okay point if you
straight up push it up bring it down
close to the floor kick it up and bring
it down okay
so your leg should always maintain a 90
degree angle kick it up right at the top
squeeze the gluts for one to two pounds
bring it back down and up good there you
go up pointing your heels straight up to
the ceiling like 90 degrees okay
kick it up nice squeeze it squeeze very
good small movement but this is to
engage the bottom part of your gluts
good so we're working on the outer the
bottom and your entire glitz alright now
just relax the right side okay still
staying on all fours I want you to
switch sides okay go on to the left side
good come up remember pushing up kicking
up with your hughes point it kick up
down keep a balance up and down so your
eye line just gaze slightly forward up
kick it up down and kick it up squeeze
it squeeze very good down up and down I
remember to keep breathing breathe
listen to your breathing bring it down
kick it up down up last ten more seconds
I want you to give me piles of data
kick kick kick and kick
good now your glutes will be on fire
last five more seconds keep taking and
rest it up good no get down onto the mat
okay place both heels together all right
and place your face down let's work on
frog kicks okay so your goal is to lift
your legs up okay just face down bring
it up squeeze your glutes bring it up
and squeeze so you've connected bring it
up and squeeze
hmm still working on the same part
really small movement but hold it for
one count bring it back down up and
squeeze if you want to you can relax
your head onto the mat up and squeeze
good control down do not just let it
collapse control up and squeeze down up
nice bring it up down up control let me
know if you're filling those buns good
now get up okay next workout hip thrust
you can choose to do this just on the
mat or with a low stepper okay so lie
down if you have a stepper place a
Hugh's on to the stepper hands by your
side and all I want you to do is lift
your body up again squeezing and
engaging your glutes and your hamstrings
lift it up pushing and back down so
imagine you have a string pulling you
straight up okay right through your
bellybutton squeezing and pulling back
down up good so point those heels point
those toes up squeeze the gluts and your
hamstrings very good oh and this workout
will also help you to sculpt away those
cellulites
get up and down and very good all right
still on the same workout single leg hip
thrust okay so beginners if you want to
just pay some feet both on the ground
lift one leg off okay now we want to
work on individual side so up down
before touching the floor lift it back
up and down good up and down again all
this workout with target on one side and
therefore you're adding more intensity
onto one side of your gluts up and down
very nice push it up on your toes okay
do not let it collapse push it up point
a toes and push good suck your belly in
last 15 seconds what I want to do is
swing to your right slightly bring it
down swing it slightly rotate slightly
and you should feel the outer glutes
engage even more rotate slightly down
rotate and back down good
are we ready to switch side so if you
have a stepper again you can use a
stepper which will make the workout
harder okay so don't switch the other
side right leg up left leg on to the
ground and let's go up and down push up
and back down lift it up squeeze it okay
squeeze engage and down and breathe in
alright good keep going
you are halfway there I am feeling the
burn but it's a good burn okay last 15
seconds I went to swing a little bit to
your left
let's go swing rotate down up lift it
rotate it down just a small slight twist
just to work a little bit harder
alright the outer glutes and back down
all right good that was round one
now take a shot whoo one minute break
keep yourself hydrated drink some water
you know all the workouts and we want to
push even harder for the second round
okay so wipe your sweat keep yourself
hydrated
take this time to just breathe in and
out I'm sweating I can feel my legs
working but that's exactly what we want
okay all these exercises really focuses
a lot on your glutes and your hamstrings
and also a little bit on your quads all
right so give me pure energy
again the first workout will be
finger-like lunch okay we have 15
seconds left
find your balance and let's start on the
right side all right ready Lix up look
straight ahead step forward if you need
to and let's go down and up push and up
good that's it
strong lunges okay
consciously suck your belly in tighten
your core it will help you to find your
balance and to give you a better focus
as well and look at one point I do not
look all over the place okay just focus
on one point and again do not rush the
workout for this kind of training it's
all about getting proper form getting
the form right and really just feeling
the muscles keep going down and up
whoo breathe and if you want to
challenge yourself even more what you
can do is lift is lift some weights okay
hold a couple of light dumbbells all
right now left leg forward right leg up
okay get ready keep your toes pointed
relax your right leg let all the work be
on your left side down and up pushing up
with your heels good
and just breathe
okay it's a great lower body workout you
can do this anywhere in the park and gym
at home basically all you need is an
elevated platform that's all keep going
again beginners if this is too difficult
you don't need the stepper okay just
place your foot onto the ground keep
going and shake it out okay
squat abductor okay so again maintain a
low squat position and we want to close
in and out okay draw your knees in and
out ready let's go down in out in and
out okay maintaining a low squat
position very good that's it in and out
pointing and pushing okay consciously
pushing as wide as you can bring it in
pushing as wet as you can and bring it
in in okay so again pushing closing
pushing and closing chest up right look
straight ahead and just place your hands
together keep going
you have about ten seconds left
stay low okay I know your legs on fire
you're glued on fire but stay low
ah last one and back up now get down
onto the mat for donkey kicks okay start
on all fours let's start with your right
leg use kicking up to it to the ceiling
okay let's go kick it up point it up
bring it back down point it up and down
good keep it strong
whoa pointer heels feel at the lower
part of the glutes okay
kick it up again in the last 15 seconds
give me strong pulses okay so kick it
straight up
control the movement kick it straight up
one more and stay up here let's go four
pulses kick it up up up straight up good
small pulses whoo at that intensity and
down all right the other side okay I can
see my sweat dripping onto the mat left
side bring it up heels point it up and
ready let's go kick up and back down
kick it up good and breathe okay keeping
your back flat throughout the workout so
do not rotate your hips too much okay
your hips should be in place very nice
guys keep going
kick it up ah let's go straight up up
good kick it up and now last one stay up
pulses okay kick it straight up strong
solid pulses few more keep going small
pulses feel the burn did not stop and
relax okay you need to wipe your set
let's get down onto the mat okay face
down Hue's connected and now let's go
with the Frog hips okay let's go up down
and up good squeeze right at the top
release slowly okay he's connected
really slow and lift it up spread your
knees apart as wide as possible
relax your head and pick up control down
and up keep going good lift as high as
you can squeeze a few more one more and
all right now turn over okay so choose
your option either place both Hughes on
to the stepper or without the stepper
choose your option
so again hip thrust hands by your side
let's go up and down all right good
up and down nice before your butt meets
the floor lift it up and squeeze it
control it down up and squeeze sure you
feel you should feel your glutes your
hamstrings engaged imagine that's a
string pulling you straight up okay
alright last 15 seconds I want you to
swing to the left and to the right so
lift it up swing it to the left and to
the right
do not drop stay strong stay high and
keep rotating to the left and to the
little right good haha and rest it up
alright
single leg hip thrusting okay again if
you have a step board and you want to
use it feel free or if you want to
challenge yourself use a fitness ball
okay there will challenge your stability
let's go and left leg up and push up
good squeeze up and down
pushing with your heels okay push into
the ground keeping your left leg lifted
and point it good up control down
working on one side last 15 seconds we
want to swing a little bit to the right
and keep swinging good swing just a
really small movement keep going
working on the outer part of the hips
and your glutes haha and I'll back it
down okay
wanna find a workout and you will get a
one-minute break let's go right leg up
left leg planted firmly onto the ground
lift it up and down good toes pointed
and down
and down very good stay strong hey stay
with me you're right at the end of the
second round you are doing extremely
well to third through your workout very
good keep going keep pushing last 15
seconds we want to sway a little bit to
the left
good sweet to the left squeeze the gluts
kid going huh push it up nice show me
your best move last one and I just relax
come back up ah that was round - you
okay another 1 minute break and we want
to end this workout strong with the
final round so keep yourself hydrated
wipe your sweat
Tom as you have you need to and give me
full energy
Oh
how are you feeling let me know in the
comments below if you feel your glutes
if you find this challenging or not okay
write another 15 seconds left like I
said if this is too easy for you
go ahead lift some weights okay so
choose your option as you progress make
it even more challenging for you so that
you will not feel bored all right let's
start with the right leg left leg up
step forward down and up squeeze it
let's go lower okay your final set I
want you to dig deeper and go lower
lunch lower bring your knee close to the
floor point down and push up okay slow
down and push fast slow and push good
find your balance
very nice keep going whew
you should feel wobbly and that is
absolutely normal
down and up squeeze last few more push
last one more push with the fuse and
swap over okay we have two likes so we
want to work on them equally all right
so right leg up step forward okay
find a comfortable position not too near
not too far look straight ahead
point your toes and down okay be careful
not to tilt your hips to one side okay
keep it as square as possible down it up
down and up if you want to place both
hands in the middle push up and down
very good keep going and down it up
breathe
suck your belly in control let's go
lower okay lower and up lower and up
let's go 1 2 up 1 2 ah good one - ah one
two AH alright shake it up squat
abductor okay ah holding a squat
position is never easy and now we're
even adding an adductor movement but I
know you're strong so let's stay low
let's push it in push it out squeeze it
up in and out okay
you didn't out squeeze and push it out
keep going
squeeze in and out okay push your butt
back okay so remember pushing your butt
back squeeze and open and open good
squeeze it out push on the outer glutes
squeeze on the inner thighs and push it
off good last ten seconds stay low stay
with me I can feel your legs burning
trust me I feel this workout and last
one and back up good let's get down onto
the mat donkey ticks okay choose your
option you can either start on your
right or left side okay
so lift up heels point it up and let's
go kick it up squeeze it down and up
kick straight up good heels towards the
ceiling and squeeze this is a really
good bum workout you don't even need any
equipment good and you can do this
anywhere again you don't need a lot of
space with all these exercises so grab
your workout buddy and do this workout
together okay done it up last 15 seconds
less squeeze pulse kick it up push up
push
good squeeze five four three two one
hole and down left side okay alright so
check out a little bit of unity now
let's bring your left leg up
heels point it up and just relax your
right side keeping your hips square push
up and down up and down
good remember keeping it hips squared
avoid moving your hips too much and just
gaze gently forward okay push and
breathe in breathe out as you kick up
breathe in breathe out breathe in
breathe out good last fifteen seconds
stay high and let's go kick kick kick
that's ten more you got this
pushing with the heels that's five more
four three two one holy and down okay
now facing down alright you've connected
nice out okay as wide as you can go
alright relax the upper body and let's
go lift it up squeeze it back down
squeeze it you should feel like a bump
is cramping up squeeze it down up
relaxed hips connect it to the floor
okay it's just about lifting your face
off the mat lift it up and off good
again breathe in when you're down
breathe out when you're up okay the
breathing is always out when you're
contracting your muscles good keep going
last then ten seconds down two more up
down one more up and dump all right now
oh my sweat it's like raining here right
now can you see this
it's like rain okay right hip thruster
Tasek Hughes onto the step board hands
by your sides
all right let's go up and down good
again squeeze okay if this is too easy
what I like to do is I like to place two
dumbbells just by my hips and then lift
it up and down okay
that will add more intensity and I will
be working on my butt even more good
lift it up back down up and squeeze on
your hamstrings as well this is a part
where most of us tend to knit glad all
right now say up swing to your left
right left and right keep going lift it
lift as high as you can keep swinging
and look straight up and now relax okay
single leg hip thrust here okay again if
you have a couple of dumbbells you can
place them just by your waist okay so
left leg straight up right leg down
that's your push up and back down up and
down keep a toes pointed working on your
right side
pushing up again right heels firmly onto
the ground good
this is your last workout okay and then
you have the other side last 15 seconds
I will need to stay up and swing
slightly go back down rotate slightly
and back down good we'll take down again
rotate and back down few more stay with
me stay strong and good shake it out a
little bit shake it out a little bit if
you need to and now one final workout
okay let's go your left side of your
glutes and hamstring so right leg
straight up toes pointed up and down
give me your best effort this is your
last workout final round alright and
let's keep lifting and pushing down it
up squeeze control down squeeze do not
just let your butt full of cake
push up control it down push it up and
control it back down up down up and down
all right stay up swing a little bit
rotate back down up rotate down can you
feel the difference when you rotate okay
you will be working more on the outer
part of a hips as well as a glutes
one more rotate and it just relaxed
alright that's it so now I wait to just
stretch out take a deep breath in you
have completed three rounds of glutes
and abs workout just stretch out and
I'll just hug both knees in okay squeeze
it lift your upper body up squeeze your
glutes squeeze it
feel the stretch deep into your glutes
okay and I'll just sway left and right
sue a little bit left and right release
any tension from your lower back
all right good and now what I want to do
is place both feet onto the ground bring
your right leg up okay cross over and
just grab your left thigh okay pull it
in and you should feel the stretch on
your right leg
your glutes as well as a hip flexor okay
and just breathe in we're not rushing to
go anywhere right now take a deep breath
in realize okay if you need to release
and pull it again and if you want to
close your eyes listen to your breathing
bring your heart rate down
and now switch the other side all right
grab your right hamstring and pull it in
breathe into every stretch close your
eyes
thank yourself for doing this workout
thank you sir for finishing it your body
your legs your glutes will thank you for
it and release and now I want you to
just roll over get up okay and just give
me a Cobra stretch so just relax sure to
push up stretch it out again release
your lower back okay do not sink into
your shoulders push it away from your
shoulders
good and now just bring your right leg
forward okay as far as you can and I
want to just slowly sink into the ground
and again stretching your right hip
flexor inner thighs and glutes if this
is too difficult stay up okay if you
want a deeper stretch then get on to
your elbows if this is too easy I'm Tara
flexible then reach forward choose your
option and breathe in
and I'll come up switch the other side
all right
so left leg forward go as far forward as
you can right leg extend it out and know
where your upper body slowly sink in
and I'll slowly push yourself up and I
want you to just open your arms close it
like yourself and give yourself a good
pad because you have done such an
amazing job so that was 30 minutes of
glutes and also abs workout this workout
is suitable for all levels adjust the
workout intensity according to your own
fitness level lift some weights if you
want to or reduce and regress the
workout ok so aim to do this workout at
least three times weekly and alternate
with cardio as well as upper body
workout if you like this workout if you
feel your glutes be sure to give this
workout a thumbs up share this workout
with your friends and do check out my
fitness app called fear on the App Store
or the Play Store you will be loving the
app because we will be sharing a daily
workout classes so check it out download
it and get your friends on it as well
all the best and I will see you in my
next workout bring it on